now prosecutors in germany have charged
a syrian doctor
with crimes against humanity allah musa
who is accused of torturing people
in military hospitals dominick kane on
skype from berlin dominic tell us more
about this one
the case against this individual relates
to his time working as a doctor
in military hospitals in two cities in
syria key cities at the start of the
civil war in that country namely homs
and damascus it is alleged that this
individual this defendant as we
can now call him was responsible for one
murder and numerous counts of torture
against numerous individuals
during his time as i say working in
those hospitals specifically
in the last few months of 2011 and the
first few months of 2012 what makes this
case particularly interesting
is that this individual went on in 2015
to come to syria to excuse me to syria
to germany
as many syrians did we know that more
than a million syrians came to this
country as
refugees and indeed the defendant
concerned claimed refugee status
and underwent procedures to certify
himself as a doctor who could work in
this country and indeed was working here
as a doctor in germany until the middle
of last year when he was arrested and
the allegations were put to him
now it is worth making the point that
the individual concerned this defendant
has the right to be presumed innocent
until proven guilty in this country
and as yet we don't know how he intends
to plead nor indeed do we know
when a potential date for his trial will
come
we know also that the german government
is now very keen to pursue those who it
believes
are responsible for allocate for crimes
committed crimes against humanity
committed in the syrian civil war
because they believe they can assert
the principle of universal jurisdiction
relating to war crimes that's what's
allowed them to charge this
particular individual they've also
charged two other individuals who were
already
in court cases one has been found guilty
of
uh acts of torture of enabling torture
another person their court case is
ongoing so this is the third time that a
syrian
individual has been accused of war
crimes committed
during the civil war in this case at the
start of the civil war
and again it's the third time that this
an individual such as this
claiming refugee status has found
themselves
the subject of accusations put against
them interestingly
this person like the others was
identified by other syrians genuine
refugees who come here seeking refuge
from the civil war the case is clearly
going to continue for some considerable
time
thank you dominic cain with that update
from berlin